>> Laura: NOW LONG BEFORE THE
2020 ELECTION, THE ANGLE WAS
WARNING ABOUT THE EXPLOSION OF
NO EXCUSE MAIL IN BALLOTS DURING
THE PANDEMIC.
WE ALL KNOW HOW 2020 TURNED OUT,
ESPECIALLY THE FAILED LEGAL
CHALLENGES THAT FOLLOWED THE
ELECTION.
NOW, THIS TIME THE GOP IS NOT
WAITING.
THE AP NOTING THAT ELECTION DAYS
IS NOVEMBER 8TH BUT LEGAL
CHALLENGES HAVE ALREADY BEGUN.
OF COURSE THAT HAS ALL THE USUAL
SUSPECTS CRYING FOUL.
>> THEY COULD LET THE STATES
START COUNTING THOSE EARLY VOTES
AS THEY COME IN, BUT THEY DON'T
WANT TO DO THAT BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO SEW DOUBTS IN THE
RESULTS.
>> WHAT THE VOTERS OUT THERE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND IS WHAT THEY
GUYS DIDN'T ACCOMPLISH WITH BEAR
SPRAY AND BATONS AND BAY NETS ON
JANUARY 6TH THEY'RE NOW TRYING
TO DO WITH VOTER SUPPRESSION.
>> Laura: THEY'RE UPSET BECAUSE
IT'S WORKING.
LAST YEAR THE RNC WON A
CHALLENGE AGAINST MICHIGAN
DEMOCRAT SECRETARY OF STATE
OVERRULES ON HOW POLL
CHALLENGERS CAN OPERATE.
THEY ALSO WON LEGAL CHALLENGES
IN NEVADA AND ARIZONA OVER THE
APPOINTMENT OF POLL WORKERS.
IN WISCONSIN THEY WON ON THE
ISSUE OF BALLOT CURING WHICH IS
A PROCESS WHERE VOTERS CAN FIX
PROBLEMS WITH THEIR BALLOTS SO
THEY CAN ACTUALLY BE COUNTED.
WISCONSIN' HIGH COURT ALSO FOUND
THE USE OF DROP BOXES TO BE
ILLEGAL.
YAY.
JOINING ME NOW IS TEXAS SENATOR
TED CRUZ AUTHOR OF THE
APPROPRIATELY TITLED JUSTICE
CORRUPTED HOW THE LEFT
WEAPONIZED OUR LEGAL SYSTEM.
SENATOR CONGRATS ON THE BOOK.
THERE'S PENDING LITIGATION ALSO
IN PENNSYLVANIA WHERE THE
SECRETARY OF THE COMMONWEALTH
THERE JUST ANNOUNCED IT COULD
TAKE DAYS TO COUNT ALL THE
VOTES.
HOW ARE WE STILL ALLOWING THIS
TO HAPPEN IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA?
>> YOU KNOW, IT IS REALLY
RIDICULOUS AND SEEMS THE PLACES
WHERE IT TAKES DAYS TO COUNT THE
VOTES, THEY ALWAYS END UP BEING
THESE BRIGHT BLUE CITIES WHERE
DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING TO GET THE
VOTES THEY NEED TO TRY TO WIN AN
ELECTION.
HOW COME THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
MANAGES TO ACTUALLY FINISH OUR
COUNTING ON ELECTION NIGHT AND
GET A RESULT?
YOU KNOW, THE BOOK THAT I HAVE
THAT CAME OUT THIS WEEK, JUSTICE
CORRUPT READY GOESS INTO THE
HISTORY OF VOTER FRAUD AND HOW
THIS GOES INTO OUR DEMOCRACY AND
WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW
PARTICULARLY IN 2020 IS
DEMOCRATS TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THE
COVID CRISIS TO CHANGE THE RULES
AND CHANGE THE RULES IN A WAY
THAT ENCOURAGED MORE VOTER
FRAUD.
THEY DID THINGS LIKE PUT IN
PLACE UNIVERSAL MAIL-IN BALLOTS
IN SOME STATES, EVEN THOUGH IT
IS CLEAR THAT MAIL-IN BALLOTS
MAKE VOTER FRAUD MORE LIKELY.
THEY DID THINGS LIKE PUTTING IN
PLACE UNMANNED DROP BOXES WHICH
AGAIN INVITE VOTER FRAUD.
THEY DO SO BY DOING THINGS LIKE
FACILITATING BALLOT HARVESTING
WHICH READILY INVITES FRAUD
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS PAID POLITICAL
OPERATIVES TO HANDLE OTHER
PEOPLE'S BALLOTS, TO INFLUENCE
VULNERABLE VOTERS AND IF THEY
DON'T LIKE THE WAY THE VOTER
VOTES TO THROW AWAY THEIR VOTES.
ALL OF THAT IS DETAILED IN
JUSTICE CORRUPTED AS WELL AS THE
LEGAL BATTLES GOING FORWARD.
>> Laura: SENATOR, THIS MAY DEFY
REALITY BUT KJP SAYS THAT HIGH
VOTER TURNOUT AND VOTER
SUPPRESSION AREN'T REALLY
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE.
WATCH.
.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR THAT, BASED ON THE BIG
LIE, THERE HAVE BEEN A HOST OF
ANTI VOTER POLICIES FORCED ON
STATES THAT CHALLENGE AMERICA'S
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO VOTE.
HIGH TURNOUT AND VOTER
SUPPRESSION CAN TAKE PLACE AT
THE SAME TIME.
>> Laura: SENATOR, THEY WERE
TRYING TO TAG GEORGIA WITH THIS
THAT THIS WAS VOTER SUPPRESSION
TO HAVE VERITY INTEGRITY LAWS
TUNED UP FOR TIMES.
AND NOW WE HAVE RECORD TURNOUT
ALREADY IN THE EARLY VOTING
THERE.
>> YEP.
YEAH, LOOK, THIS IS ALL GAS
LIGHTING.
THIS BIDEN WHITE HOUSE IS THE
MOST DISHONEST WHITE HOUSE WE'VE
EVER SEEN.
KARIN JEANNE-PIERRE, SHE LIES ON
A DAILY BASIS.
WHAT SHE JUST SAID -- AND THE
BOOK GETS INTO GEORGIA'S VOTER
INTEGRITY LAW AND TEXAS VOTER
INTEGRITY LAW AND THE LIES THIS
WHITE HOUSE AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAVE TOLD.
THIS IS SOARING BECAUSE WHEN
PEOPLE HAVE CONFIDENCE IN VOTER
ELECTION THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO
TURN OUT.
I'VE BEEN FIGHTING VOTER FRAUD
FOR TWO DECADES, WHIFFS THE
SOLICITOR IN TEXAS I LED BEFORE
THE SUPREME COURT DEFENDING
PHOTO IDs FOR VOTING AND WENT TO
THE SCORE 6-3 THE COURT UPHELD
VETO IDs FOR VOTING THE OPINION
WRITTEN BY JUSTICE JOHN PAUL
STEVENS WHICH AS YOU KNOW WAS
ONE OF THE LEADING LIBERALS ON
THE COURT WHO SAID PROTECTING
THE INTEGRITY OF ELECTION
ENHANCES EVERYONE'S CONFIDENCE
IN DEMOCRACY BECAUSE IT PREVENTS
YOUR VOTE FROM BEING STOLEN.
BUT TODAY'S BIDEN WHITE HOUSE,
THEY WANT A SYSTEM WHERE MORE
FRAUD IS POSSIBLE.
AND WHAT THIS BOOK IS ALL ABOUT
IS THAT, UNDER BARACK OBAMA AND
NOW EVEN MORE SO UNDER JOE
BIDEN, THEY HAVE POLITICIZED THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, THE FBI,
THE IRS, THE CIA, THE ENTIRE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, AND THEY'RE
USING IT AS A WEAPON TO TARGET
AND ATTACK THEIR ENEMIES.
IT'S PROFOUNDLY DANGEROUS.
AND IT IS A FUNDAMENTAL THREAT
TO OUR LIBERTIES.
>> Laura: AND I HOPE THE SENATE,
IF IT RETURNS INTO REPUBLICAN
HANDS, THE SENATE -- THE
REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED SENATE
ACTUALLY IS ABLE TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT ALL THIS.
SENATOR, ELON MUSK NOW TAKES THE
REIGNS AT TWITTER, SPEAKING OF
TEXAS BECAUSE HE'S MOVED HIS
OPERATION TO TEXAS, WHAT DO YOU
THINK IS GOING TO HAPPEN NOW
THAT ALL OF THIS LUNACY PERHAPS
WILL END WITH THE CENSORSHIP
WITH OPPOSING VIEWPOINTS?
>> LOOK, I THINK ELON MUSK'S
BUYING TWITTER IS ONE OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENTS
FOR FREE SPEECH IN MODERN TIMES.
BIG TECH IS THE SINGLE GREATEST
THREAT TO FREE SPEECH AND TO
FREE AND FAIR ELECTIONS WE HAVE
IN AMERICA, AND TWITTER WAS
BRAZEN ABOUT IT, ABOUT SILENCING
AND CENSORING CONSERVETIVES.
ELON MUSK PUT A LOT OF MONEY
INTO IT AND HE SAID HE WANTS IT
TO BE A HAVEN FOR FREE SPEECH,
FOR PEOPLE TO SPEAK AND DEBATE
AND BE A TOWN SQUARE OF PUBLIC
DEMOCRACY.
I THINK THAT IS TREMENDOUS, HE
FIRED THE TOP EXECUTIVES, THAT
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
HE NEEDED TO CLEAN HOUSE AT THE
TOP LEVEL.
AND SIMPLY ALLOWING FREE SPEECH
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
NEXT YEAR, WHEN REPUBLICANS TAKE
A MAJORITY, AND I'M RIGHT NOW IN
THE MIDDLE OF A NATION-WIDE
17-STATE BUS TOUR, I SPENT ALL
DAY TODAY CAMPAIGNING WITH
HERSCHEL WALKER IN GEORGIA.
WHEN WE TAKE THE MAJORITY IN
BOTH HOUSES, WHICH I BELIEVE WE
WILL, I'M NEXT IN LINE TO CHAIR
THE SENATE COMMERCE COMMITTEE
AND YOU CAN BE ASSURED WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE HEARINGS EXAMINING
BIG TECH CENSORSHIP AND FIGHTING
TO PROTECT F